extinction rebellion are back in their
headlines
this time halting the distribution of
millions of newspapers across the
country
midway through 10 days of action they
stopped lorries leaving major printing
sites in hertfordshire and
merseyside claiming the newspapers
influenced by their owners
are not doing enough to highlight the
climate emergency
every person who works on a news
international or a male newspaper knows
what
story is and isn't acceptable for their
bosses
and their bosses know that because they
know what's acceptable to
rupert murdoch or to rothermere or to
any of the other five billionaires who
run
70 of our our media
the morning's newsstands told the story
of the night
but not in print deliveries of the
papers targeted
the sun the mail the times the financial
times
and the telegraph had clearly been badly
hit
the sun said the activists were out of
touch
pointing to a david attenborough article
on climate change in today's edition
placed before the protests had even
begun
the sun was running uh a page 10 a full
page
um opinion piece by david attenborough
with really sort of helpful useful
practical tips for readers on uh exactly
climate change in their daily lives
which they now can't read so that feels
like a little bit of an own goal
from an extinction rebellion the prime
minister tweeted a free press is vital
in holding the government
and other powerful institutions to
account on
issues critical for the future of our
country
including the fight against climate
change it is completely unacceptable to
seek to limit the public's access to
news in this way
extinction rebellion says it's trying to
hold a mirror
to media moguls like rupert murdoch
whose vast
publishing stable includes the sun and
the times
we feel that the the large billionaire
press in the united kingdom
is complacent about climate action many
of them are opposed to many
aspects of climate action and we feel
the complacency is a threat to britain
but the climate change campaigners are
navigating a thin line between
generating
awareness and alienating the people
they're trying to influence
in general too many of our newspapers
are ignoring
climate change some are even publishing
articles which are
inaccurate misleading and promote
climate change denial
so we do need more coverage of climate
change but i'm not convinced that this
is the right way
for extinction rebellion to highlight
this issue
protesters have now moved on to other
targets
scaling a crane at houston station in
protest against
hs2 many in the group see any attention
they get for the cause as a success
whatever the inconvenience it causes
lisa holland sky news